per le a tutti ragazzi è benvenuta altro
sto facendo un video di happy with con
la maglia rossa che tipo un abominio
cioè tipo ho fatto sempre video di è più
visco la maglia blu con la maglia rossa
significa questo episodio deve succedere
qualcosa di speciale per tutti ragazzi e
bevete questo video sono fa dj oggi
siamo tornati su happy with partiamo
allora deve succedere davvero qualcosa
se non ha senso blu matt piano casa
partiamo dalla prima che tanto e cazzuto
livello cosa si è fumato il tizio che ha
fatto sto livello santo iddio mi scusi
beh allegro almeno è molto più allegro
di quanto pensassi va bene e non è tanto
il fatto del parecchio più allegro di
quanto pensassi epic bottle flips che
ovviamente sta esplodendo sta roba dei
botto il flip stragà non l'ho capita
perché rifiuti land hotin di sbotto
serio replay ok cosa come c'è quindi ho
già vinto è stato b semplice del
previsto in realtà ci regali per questo
cielo la maglia rossa perché non può
essere successo davvero da fermi se
avete visto l'ultimo episodio di fv se
non questo quello prima sapete quanto è
difficile mettere la bottiglia tritta
quindi non è possibile che sia caduta
così non ci posso credere rock swing
cartoon ok bravissimo dovevi compensare
il fatto che il livello di prima era
andato troppo bene quindi le sei fatto
cagare come me a scuola prendeva un 9
poi prendevo un 2 coi prendevo un altro
no non è vero non ho mai preso un 9 in
vita mia perfetto che entrata miracolosa
fai così apre fatto bene store in chiave
rock swing colorato che abbia mai visto
sto vomitando arcobaleni let's go out
ok ovviamente sto diventando abbastanza
bravo coi rock swing ci sono volute solo
120 puntate di è primi sei per carità di
dio neanche troppe hold up kids and on
preside spacebar va bene
ecco doveva succedere questa cosa zia è
normale quali fisica sto andando avanti
scusate cosa mi sto muovendo con la
forza delle natiche
ok gre bon de beaumont e gravare su
questo punto
benvenuto un mezzo infarto prova ben
prendete stare calmi tutti venata versus
antiquità maghetto è vabbè sono vivo
cosa non mi sono neanche dice va bene va
bene non importa non facciamo
purtroppo che mons sono curioso di
vedere che cosa mi chiede bellissimo bel
meraviglioso il più bella che io abbia
mai visto in tutta la mia vita si è
anche fatto di ketamina probabilmente
già ora che tam all that are help the
attack mister ma io ho visto fare dove
per due la vittoria sta minchia che come
faccio a vincere impossibile watermelon
che guscio di culo
non so che ho fatto non ho idea red bol
2 unicato succedono le cose che tiro a
caso e faccio cose che non mi mancava
questo non potevo farlo a livello senza
questa cosa veramente un beat
meraviglioso ragazzi non credo che
skrillex sappia fare di meglio
mi sorprendo lì infatti a giocare asti
livelli oggi non so perché potete
abbassare il volume di happiness in
generale che palle perfette grazie ho
giocato alla fi ne the friend is l'altro
giorno fa meno paura
ok è un livello allegro ragazzi potete
che sono livelli allegri poema le alghe
smash revolution per quest'anno si prega
vi dovete darvi giuro prendete delle
cazzo di tisane che aprono le mi avete
perché fate casino io vi giuro che
stanotte non dormo poker ti come si fa
aiuto non posso muovere le braccia sono
troppo pesanti
scusami luke vieni nonno portami la
bottiglia che sono felice grazie
prossimo prossimo prossimo il raduno
degli haters che sta facendo ed a sei
scemo lo schiacciato il culo va bene
ragazzi ma basta quanta gente c'è all
anas faccio mai poi wengen
pine pineapple [__] ho vinto
perfetto interactive tablet bello tra
l'altro il tablet di nuova generazione
mi dicono sia acceso passcode 3698
carega vi giuro era il mio una volta io
avevo 3698 veramente perché faceva la l
al contrario come cazzo fanno a saperlo
brutti stronzi sapevano la mia password
del telefono stivale detti lo cambia
volevi farmi il telefono per sbloccarlo
non potete hangouts a palau rebecca
ptrebbe che avete sbagliato a scrivere
rebecca ragazzi ei che cazzo di dialogo
è rebecca partners neanche se ne è
andata come sempre da ma le posso non
abbiamo la presenti qui torniamo
indietro funzione che figata hanno fatto
un telefono facciamo fotocamera come mai
oggi sono più bello del solito qual è il
problema quando ti si apre la fotocamera
frontale senza preavviso e io sono molto
peggio di così just eat mi ordinò al
sushi ordina sushi ordine al sushi
ragazzi ordinato il sushi mi arriverà al
sushi sono convinto è più il
l'applicazione di happy with
bellissimo applicazione della vita
ragazze ti fa finire le partite non c'è
l'applicazione del genere per finire
anche le verifiche non si sarà capirà
mid of the gods la piramide degli ideali
fino a un livello di quelli d'avventura
figli mi scusi signor servente non
volevo
ecco infatti non meno infatti non ha
fatto un cazzo ecco se contento signor
serpente grazie è già iniziata l'ora di
educazione fisica sono arrivato il
ritardo è la madonna quanta tragedia ma
poi tal altro perché io che mi sta
tenendo un piede sulle natiche qual è il
problema
che figata che ha fatto benissimo da
quando non vede un livello così figo
cioè primis perfetto ok che va quorum lo
ferito ragazzi non ho capito dove è
andato ma lo ferito ha tirato le
trappole sosto lungo brutto deficiente
crepa non c'è niente che una bici non
possa fare ragazze minchia che svetta
forte poi è morto ce l'ho fatta ho
battuto horus quindi ho vinto livello
ragazzi facciamo l'unboxing ronaldo toti
in a pec non è proprio ronaldo ma va
bene a nubi testa di culo vorresti
riprendersi la rivincita per prima testa
di merda forse solo un serpente mi
spiace information center a cia di fare
perché c'è certamente nelle piramidi
mettono all information center tipo
negli hotel avere ragazzi torniamo
indietro l'importante è che abbiamo
capito quali sono nemici quindi mi manca
isis vorrei mai che esplodesse isis
porcaccia [__] è morto gli occhi sono
schiacciate un a cui ruota però lo
batterò lo stesso perché io può
ciao isis come stai facile con la ruota
sbagliata e ma tanto io ti batto lo
stesso che sono più forze tech ragazzi
se vinco sto livello con la ruota sbanca
tanta roba
ok
ecco infatti lo sapevo ci siamo ragazzi
stavolta prova a non farmi g min chiare
la ruota in partenza cosa che non è
stata proprio il massimo
ok manca l'ultimo l'ultimo colpo ragazzi
l'ultimo colpo pam cazzo isis di merda
su chi ama non ce l'ho più va beh cosa
potrebbe essere un dettaglio gli stai
proprio umiliando frutta stronzo beccati
st biciclettata in bocca perché in
realtà un morto non è morto se continua
a combattere fa vj 2016 forza forza che
crepe la forza che crepa sta morendo che
i cui pezzi dei miei arti a caso è morta
anche se sono morto io questo per me
vale come vittoria scrivi the box non
facciamo le schede dei box che da una
vita che non lo faccio e che adesso non
riesco più a fare un cazzo quindi non
esco a fare neanche più a far questo
ecco come non è però la posizione comoda
per dormire fermi perfetto anche per
cadere verso sinistra quindi stiamo
fallendo però vabbè leggett challenge
cos'è sta roba costante di dio come
dovrei vincere spiega mi quali problemi
come faccia vincere ma non puoi cioè non
con questo personaggio almeno perfetto
ma che ce frega cos'ha fatto livello 2
per miracolo fatto livello 1 figurati a
queste di vermi che meno male
ok come stili si forse c'è speranza
forze si lisi kipling e la madonna che
ninja normal
[__] non so se avete capito
[__] non lo rifaccio bloccheranno
che casa in blu kram è tipo bottone solo
non è proprio la stessa cosa
ok adesso la stessa cosa di motorland
veloce veloce ma cosa fa come fa a
cagliare ma dai ma zero
vai da una vita che giocare primis come
mika fai a morire così porca eva come
poi dopo anni di è più insaporire con un
decerebrato zio è incredibile fa
incazzare queste minchiate prossimo a un
thank montagna grassa no non è vero
bisoli e grassi si vuol dire erboso lega
bello perché certo in una montagna
erbosa puoi fare queste cose mi sembra
ovvio
vabbè però stesse sai tutti calmi dovete
stare tutti calmi calmatevi che è peggio
di horus sto livello live ho calciato
una roccia enorme perfetto perfetto i
pipistrelli nella bat caverna capitolato
ragazzi non so perché a me fa un povero
iran images trenino bisoli lilia
adotterei so troppo belli a caso dai vai
da tua madre però ebbe la pesante credo
che ci voglia un po'di skrillex 4
calmi che sta succedendo
ok perfetto riprendiamo
ce la puoi fare [__] va bè ragazzi
niente skrillex niente montagne e fotte
sega episodio è stato in quanto strano
andare sulle montagne robe del genere
prova skrillex non aiuta in questi casi
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
devo andare a vendere il sushi che mi è
arrivato perché l'ho ordinato suonerà
tra 3 2 1
apro sarebbe stato figo cose temi del
momento è un mi piace ai capace di
facebook e come l'iscrizione sono
serviti sia idrici vi diamo prossimo
video belle ragazze